hey guys it's Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
candy crush soda saga level to 41
through it with tips and this is a
really tough level
fortunately the strategy isn't very
complex but you need to get a good setup
and you need to get things to go your
way so in the first room we don't really
the first one isn't so bad but we do
want to think about bringing a couple
specials with us into the next room
without wasting a whole lot of moves to
get there so so far has been pretty
straightforward I have a bear here and a
bear here and I'm just scamming and I
don't really see any good setups for a
color bomb or the coloring candy but
that's the sort of thing I'm looking for
because like it's a lot easier to set
one up in this room than it is in the
next game so
so I am gonna want to move along three
stripes and things aren't really gonna
make that big of a difference so I went
ahead and tried to get a purple to fall
here there's always a chance that a
purple will fall from the top and that
will come out that way but didn't happen
set off this finish now we have a color
bomb here and we took out the last bear
so we got a little bit of something to
work with
so the the Bears are all for all
intensive purposes are below all this
ice and this thick honey at the bottom
so I'm going to definitely try to make
this into a combo if I keeneland using
over the color at this point won't do
anything at all and combo enough with
one fish will be okay but we're gonna
try to do something a little bit better
if you can what stuff is that there's
not a lot of space so you can get stuck
here and end up having to use it anyway
so we're trying to avoid that all right
so I think this I think with a stripe of
you pretty good we got 26 moves left so
hopefully that will change things up a
little bit and we'll be able to work our
way down
we won we definitely want to start
breaking through this now we'll look for
specials that they can find them and we
did have we have this year when I was
able to put a strike together with it so
that's something that you're gonna want
to do and then you'll see as we take the
layers down that we have some more
specials hidden inside here so we're
gonna try to do the exact same thing
with those especially this wraps over
here if we can so let's think about this
we have these two right oh really in the
way right here
okay so here's a straight
we'll be able to drop that down but we
have to we have to hit it again in order
to make that happen so
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna match
this when we move it up so it doesn't
take this out was it is going to screw
that up
I decided to do it this way it's dead
I'll leave that one there and you do it
this way
and we'll just go ahead and make this
above it first
all right so we're down to only a few
moves left now 11 it sounds like a lot
but we still have like layers on this
and layers are needs so we do we do want
to make something with this but a fish
plus the rap isn't gonna be that great
actually firing off the rat by itself
would be better because it'll explode
twice most we have here we got a stripe
that's just waiting we're gonna have
some other stuffs out here but this is
all kind of a jumble up top um I'm gonna
make this fish just to kind of drop
things in the place and see where we
come up with
so we can do the we do a finish plus the
wrapped here strike that it's not gonna
go with the wrapped but we'll be able to
shoot it up I think yeah so I'm just
gonna go ahead and do that I'm gonna
drop these purple and I'm just going to
go ahead and fire this this wrapped off
right here and I was hoping that would
bring a green close enough but it did
you know if we do this a little bit so
now five moves question is
and then we're gonna make the collar
bone million here all them just I'm just
wondering where we're going with this
all right here I like the color bomb
fish and when we do that that's also
going to set off the rap because the
Reds gonna disappear so I like that for
sure and that's that's all we had to do
um I mean you could get fancy and make a
collar bomb over here and whatever but
all you really have to do is make that
match right there so that's the way I
you know I would approach it try to just
try to make a collar bomb or a collar in
candy to color bottoms in the first room
and bring them down if you can anything
like that you can see it'll really help
out and just really think about how
you're gonna use those specials in the
second room don't just start firing
things off randomly like hopefully you
can see with my thought process there
and the way I made the decisions then
you know I was pretty methodical about
moving down and using those trap
specials that are inside the ice on the
way to them to the the honey so I hope
this helps please subscribe to our
channel to support us and then you'll be
able to find out when we make new videos
like this and like the video if you
found it helpful I'll be making more
soon thanks